[Musique]
quatre à six semaines et ça les grandes
au ministre de la santé ou sa vie
c'était une secte donc ça désormais d'en
laisser quelqu'un qui a gardé le
président de la république et les fous
donc ça veut dire qu'à partir du 15
avril
on se dit qu'on a passé le gros de la
vague on espère que la campagne de
vaccination aura suffisamment d'effets
pour commencer à alléger les
restrictions c'est ça qu'a voulu dire le
président on est un peu abasourdi par la
paix et la violence de décision qui a
été prise et on sait très bien voilà
qu'il ya un appel qui a été fait nicolas
sarkozy soutenue en premier lieu par son
épouse carla qui a posté cette photo ce
message sur instagram hier après midi
selon un principe de corps qui tient la
magistrature selon aussi un autre
actionne que les juges ne doivent des
explications à personne bienvenue en
france nous ne sommes pas dans une
république bananière de seul le mardi 2
mars et vous avez 9h02 j'hésite entre
puis je me suis dit que j'ai réussi
d'action et que c'était important
participer au sidaction
j'ai pas le corps à chanter mais je
pense que c'est important de garder ses
engagements il est pas bon que les
hommes politiques se mêlent de justice
oui mais il n'est pas bon que la justice
se mêlent de politique
or le sentiment qu'on a aujourd'hui
c'est que la justice a fait de la
politique dans cette affaire est pour
moi comme beaucoup de français
d'ailleurs spontanément je vais vous
expliquer pourquoi
cette décision me semble insensé
disproportionnée extravagantes
parmi les drôles de méthodes du pnm dans
ce dossier il y en a sur lesquels nous
attendons que la lumière soit faite je
veux parler de l'épluchage des relevés
téléphoniques de nombreux avocats une
dérive selon le juge van ruymbeke des
méthodes de barbouzes selon leurs
propres termes sur le garde des sceaux
je pense que nicolas sarkozy compte tenu
de la jurisprudence fillon si nicolas
sarkozy souhaite être candidat à la
présidentielle
eh bien il doit l'être on ne se combat
pas par l'intermédiaire de magistrats
qui pourrait ainsi décider qui peut se
présenter et qui ne peux pas je ne
m'exprime pas sur une décision de
justice tous les français sont
justiciables les
du plus haut sommet au plus haut plus en
inde
c'est normal je ne commente jamais les
décisions de justice et je les commande
pas a fortiori y compris quand il s'agit
d'un ancien président et seul quel droit
ce ministre de l'intérieur gérald
darmanin qui a apporté son soutien à
nicolas sarkozy on s'autorise à penser
dans les milieux autorisés qu'un accord
secret pourrait être signé prochainement
mais on n'est pas sûr pour quelqu'un qui
ne commente pas une question de justice
dit non je ne fais jamais vous pourrez
d'ailleurs le vérifier mais ils ont
décidé de franchir la ligne rouge de la
politisation de la justice
je pense que s'il clientes thierry
herzog était tout autre que nicolas
sarkozy
il ya peu de chances que ces écoutes ont
été transmises au parquet on nous a
caché un classement sans suite on nous a
caché des éléments à décharge que nous
avons tenté d'exploiter bien tardivement
et je pense que il faudra que chacun
fasse le ménage devant sa porte
les juges ne font pas de politique ni le
tribunal correctionnel ni le parquet
national financiers je ne tiens pas de
comptabilité dans les 605 affaires qui
sont actuellement en cours au parquet
national financier à qui appartiennent
les personnalités qui apparaissent dans
environ 10% de ces affaires et puis il
ya jean luc mélenchon jean luc mélenchon
dont je vous propose de regarder le
tweet sarkozy condamné macron
débarrasser d'un sérieux rival jean luc
mélenchon encore une fois est obsédé par
les élections présidentielles qui ne
regarde qui regarde tous traversent ce
seul prisme là je veux dire je trouve
que ça n'appelle même pas de commentaire
tellement ces propos sont déplacés et
sans aucune cohérence
nicolas sarkozy a dit très clairement
qu'il n'entendait plus s'engager dans la
vie publique
donc aujourd'hui les suppositions
monsieur mélenchon de qui que ce soit
d'autre n'ont que peu d'importance
de son côté nicolas sarkozy fera appel
et parle d'un combat qu'il mènera
jusqu'à la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme s'il le faut